exec deputy executive editor of chosen
daily newspaper in Korea which is the
largest newspaper in Korea and I would
like to talk about the education I think
Korea's main success today as globally
known is because of the education it's a
uniform education everybody will have
what would have the opportunity for
school college or whatever they want as
long as they aspire to study may be
studying for you with sounds boring but
i think you know getting the knowledge
into your head getting the knowledge and
access to the knowledge and create
something out of that knowledge will
bring wealth to the nation and i think
that's what created for the past 50
years and i think and the i think the
englisha president are you listening
good job in increasing the education
infrastructure here in Indonesia but I
think I shouldn't just be afraid to his
nature along I think education is what
everybody can you know make a dream or
make their dream come true or in the
future so you should put you should put
more resources in the school system you
should try to you know bring out any
more teachers into the good schools and
not only just teachers in schools the
real teachers in the society but you
know I will school succeeded in in a
society so you can have a financier
actually going to school and teach kids
and at least a show then you know what
the future can be for them successful
politician Ricky go to school teacher so
I think if you have more of these inner
inner operability within sectors to
focus more on health kitchen I think
there were playing success to the
developing nations as well now once you
achieve that level such as Korea we do
have any film education up until high
school and almost eighty percent of high
school kids go in color
Korea the next question for us now is
how to create a creative infrastructure
so that they can bring in their valuated
value-added knowledge into the global
economy that's our next phase but I
think in Asia and such as developing
nations such as Malaysia and other
countries can can do this a lot faster
than we do because you may you know take
a look at our problems are over our
educational systems and just sort of
leapfrog into the future right now the
Chinese are having a very universal
educational system that's implementing
and it's gaining a lot of valuated I
guess valuated up values into the
Chinese economy so same thing I should
have a desire passion and the will to
implement a widespread uniform education
system in the auditory countries that we
all have a better world that's my answer
I